olá é um eu vou começar essa fala me
descortinando porque através da minha
imagem eu já passei uma muita mensagem
errada então eu não quero fazer isso
dessa vez
então eu sei que aqui com essa roupitcha
e tal eu pareço amaciam super importante
e que sabe o que está fazendo mas não é
verdade
nervosa talvez eu esqueci o que eu vou
falar hoje
então vou tirar este salto na vizinha
para poder relaxar e falar sobre o que
eu realmente vem falar
dentre outras coisas eu já trabalhei
como modelo e como modelo
é o que eu ajudava a fazer é é que o
ajudava a sustentar uma narrativa
relacionada ao consumo
eu através da minha imagem passava para
as pessoas a idéia de que uma vez que
elas consumissem o produto ou serviço
que eu estava ajudando a vender
elas estariam felizes como eu parecia
aquelas fotos cheia de photoshop
maquiagem e tudo mais gargalhando muito
espontaneamente à então como modelo eu
era parte dessa narrativa do consumo e
as coisas começaram a mudar
eu é que o modelo foi viajar morei na
tailândia na china e na índia
e nesses lugares eu comecei a entrar em
contato com o outro lado do consumo que
eu não tinha a menor consciência é na
china eu vi as pessoas usando máscara
para poder respirar por causa da
poluição causada pelas fábricas
eu vi trabalho escravo
é eu vi na índia rios super poluído
cheios de resíduos tóxicos é despejado
por indústrias desculpa e eu comecei a
perceber como que tinha um lado do
consumo
eu não tinha a menor consciência que
tudo aquilo ali estava a lidar ligado
com as compras que eu fazia que eu
ajudava as pessoas a fazer é então eu
comecei a ganhar consciência que por
trás de tudo que você compra tem ali um
impacto social e ambiental desde o
processo de extração daquele recurso
natural até o processo de produção é
transporte distribuição e finalmente
descarte naquele produto tem um impacto
acontecendo é corta a cena volta ao
brasil o tampão depois começa a estudar
sustentabilidade é e econômicas
alternativas como economia colaborativa
economia do compartilhamento e me
queixei muito sobre o porquê as pessoas
consomem de onde vem o consumo é o que
motiva as pessoas a consumir
eu cheguei a algumas respostas que eu
vou compartilhar com vocês
a primeira delas é é que os pessoas
consomem por que por uma necessidade
muito muito básica de todo ser humano
que ele sentir aceito e sente amada
sentir pertencimento é e quando a
propaganda fala pra você o tempo todo
que quando você tiver isso ou aquilo aí
sim você vai ser legal e aí por você ser
legal aí sim você vai ser digno de ser
amados ter amigos e né e tudo mais
não é de espantar que as pessoas comecem
a comprar feito loucas né então tem esse
lado tem o outro lado é enfim que na
verdade não há nenhum outro lado é de
onde que surge esse lugar do dessa
propaganda que é a narrativa do
crescimento econômico
hoje na nossa sociedade o crescimento
econômico ele virou o maior deus de
todos a gente tudo gente faz pelo
crescimento
o mico e ele guia nossas vidas é então
assim uma um exemplo muito simples de
como isso ia nossas vidas é que o nosso
maior a nossa maior métrica de sucesso
como país é ou como sociedade é o
consumo o pib é baseado nisso é baseado
na quantidade de bens e serviços
produzidos e consumidos
é isso que diz pra gente se a gente está
indo bem ou não é só isso o que diz pra
gente a gente está indo bem ou não
então quando você vê que esse é o nosso
maior guia de sucesso ea gente pensa que
a gente tá no planeta finito com
recursos finitos e que esse crescimento
na teoria é infinito
a gente vai ter com a ação não fecha não
dá pra sair consumindo no planeta que
vai acabar é que não têm capacitação tem
tempo para se regenerar a outra coisa
que eu vi relacionado com ao o
crescimento na verdade que vem muito
junto da narrativa do crescimento é a
ideia do da monetização da vida foi lá
que eu chamo assim que é o seguinte
exemplo o bolo você vê uma criança ela é
cheia de dons e talentos uma criança lá
que desenha super bem e aí os pais
dessas crianças ficam nervosos porque
eles querem encaixar a criança numa
caixinha de um produto que pode ser
vendido
aí começa aí o menino vai ser designer
porque ele tenha bem a não menos artista
plástico vai ser que teto enquanto não
conseguir transformar isso que essa
criança é um produto que pode ser
vendido ou consumido eu não me arquiteto
ea gente faz isso o tempo todo com as
relações com as pessoas com tudo isso é
parte de uma conseqüência dessa dessa
lógica de temos que crescer temos que
crescer economicamente é esse é um
pequeno exemplo mas junto da idéia do
crescimento econômico também tem uma
narrativa é que vem muito acoplada que a
idéia da escassez
essa idéia de escassez é uma idéia
artificial é uma ideia que é falado pra
gente a vida toda que não têm recursos
suficientes para todo mundo que não tem
suficiente pra todo mundo que a gente
tem que lutar e competir por recursos
porque é e você tem que garantir o seu é
porque está todo mundo tentando tirar o
seu então você tem que cuidar do que
você pensa não pode compartilhar com as
pessoas é porque está todo mundo em
competição
então você vê por exemplo é no colégio
que falam você tem que ser o melhor
aluno da sala o primeiro do vestibular
ou quando você vai pro celular para o
trabalho e aí tem o funcionário do mês
essas todas são formas de recompensa é e
de reconhecimento que são baseadas no
individual
a gente não tem reconhecimento e
recompensa coletiva já viu alguém
ganhando o prêmio porque é que você que
mais ajuda às outras a mais legal com as
outras mas colabora
a gente não tem isso então quando a vida
inteira você ensinar você tem que ser
melhor que os outros para garantir o seu
porque não vai ter pra todo mundo
é óbvio que as pessoas começam a
competir entre si e ska se aos recursos
que elas têm
quando eu vi quando eu entendi esse
cenário não bateu aquela coisa assim do
tipo eu tenho dois caminhos ou eu vou
aceitar a vida como ela é tomar o
rivotril zinho pra ver se eu fico mais
em ou fazer uma coisa pra mudar é e
porque eu tô aqui nesse tapete vermelho
agora vocês devem saber qual foi o
caminho que eu também vou fazer alguma
coisa pra fazer diferente e aí eu
resolvi botar em prática uma idéia que
estava na minha cabeça meio maluca eu
quis criar uma rede de colaboração de
vida entre vizinhos pra as pessoas
compartilharem coisas umas com as outras
eu cheguei em casa um dia peguei uma
cartolina fiz como se fosse uma planilha
de excel cheia de coloninha número botei
nome
preciso de ver meu apartamento meu
telefone e escrevi lá que eu precisava
de um desentupidor de pia e colei isso
no elevador do lado do meu prédio onde
da noite a louca na cinderela tudo
escondido assim colher um negócio na
parede menção da rapina
é isso e aí fui pra minha casa pensando
eu criei um negócio de colaboração no
meu prédio e tal e aí pra minha surpresa
15 minutos depois bati na minha porta
uma vizinha com um desentupidor de pia
na mão
assim eu tenho eu falei assim é possível
é possível negócio funciona
gente as pessoas não são mais as pessoas
querem te ajudar elas querem colaborar
com você e depois sem que isso a menina
nem conheço ela é sempre aquele papo de
elevador esquisito de para o tempo está
estranha é e aí ficava nisso e de
repente a pessoa bateu na minha porta
emprestado do jipe aplicar esse negócio
vai dar certo e aí esse foi o protótipo
do que virou depois o tem açúcar que
hoje em dia é um aplicativo que facilita
o empréstimo de objetos entre vizinhos
hoje eu tenho açúcar ajuda as pessoas a
economizar dinheiro consumir de forma
mais consciente e criar esse senso de
comunidade nas vizinhanças criar
vizinhos mais colaborativas é e aí foi
muito doido assim porque eu lancei essa
ideia o negócio do super certo hoje em
dia somos quase 100.000 vizinhos em
todos os estados do brasil mais de
12.500 bairros compartilham objetos é eu
tenho muita felicidade de dizer que 62
por cento do que as pessoas pedem um
aplicativo elas conseguem e pra você que
está pensando aí as pessoas não devolvem
brasileira malandro não é assim é menos
de 0,5 por cento das vezes que
aconteceram transações de pessoas não
devolveram alguma coisa que é um número
muito baixo é então é assim e tem açúcar
foi criado baseado nessa minha
satisfação de ser desse lugar e eu fico
muito feliz porque ele ele é baseado num
dos concelhos que mais acredito na vida
que é o gift economia nem como é chamado
o que é aí é que fica o nome em
português é mais ou menos a economia do
dom da idade ou da gratidão é que é a
idéia de que uma pessoa pode te ajudar
de forma incondicional
ou seja ela não precisa nada em troca
então por exemplo seu empréstimo pra
você uma furadeira você
precisa me dar nada de volta não precisa
nem pagar isso é preciso emprestar
alguma coisa de volta não tenha absoluta
condição só uma ajuda incondicional é
uma ajuda porque eu quero ser legal o
que acaba acontecendo nesse tipo de
economia é que isso gera um senso de
gratidão e uma vontade de passar pra
frente que faz a coisa acontecer de uma
forma incrível é então por exemplo é uma
história bem simples assim que já
aconteceu não tem açúcar tinha uma
menina que precisava de uma bota
ortopédica emprestada porque ela tinha
torcido pega ela não ia comprar lá é só
usar por duas semanas ela pegou essa
bota emprestada
quando ela foi devolver essa bota ela
levou uma cartinha e nessa cartilha ela
contava para a vizinha emprestou a onde
a bola tinha levado ela pra passear
nessas duas semanas
então ela falou essa sua bota me levou
para ver um jogo de futebol no filho eu
também fui numa exposição de arte blá
blá blá blá blá
muito obrigado e tudo mais esse tipo de
coisa esse tipo de sutileza é o tipo de
coisa que não uma transação financeira
você não vê não existe é muito diferente
de um aluguel de uma coisa é isso que
cria um senso de comunidade é isso que
cria a vontade você ajudará a próxima
pessoa e passar essa essa gratidão que
você tem pra frente é enfim esse é uma
das coisas que aconteceram não tem
açúcar tem várias outras histórias
lindas que acontecem é e pra mim essa é
por exemplo uma das principais
diferenças entre plataformas como o
cloud surfing o web os dois são
plataformas kit botam hospedados na casa
de outras pessoas só que não bebi você
paga por isso e no couchsurfing você não
paga pessoas simplesmente porque é legal
deixa eu ficar na casa dela e as
amizades que acontecem no caso de ser
fim as histórias e o cuidado que as
pessoas têm com a casa do outro é
completamente diferente de como acontece
no nbb
não que eu seja melhor que outros são
diferentes cada um cada um lugar de cada
coisa tem o seu momento mas é se a gente
está falando de criação de comunidade
local do surfe ele cria muito mais
comunidade do que o irb
e esse também é uma das intenções e
objetivos não tem açúcar e assim tem uma
uma um dado que eu acho bem bem
importante assim quando a gente começa a
pensar será que eu tenho coisa pra
emprestar prazo para compartilhar eu não
sei cara uma casa ela tem
aproximadamente 10 mil reais em coisas
que não estão sendo utilizadas
se você ainda com esse dado ainda não se
convenceu pensa que um quarto dos gastos
de uma casa e um terço do lixo produzido
em uma casa poderiam ser evitados se as
pessoas compartilhassem coisas então a
gente tem a possibilidade de fazer uma
ação simples nosso dia-a-dia a
possibilidade de mudar o mundo de mudar
o ciclo de produção das coisas de mudar
o impacto fazer um impacto ambiental e
não só isso mas conhecem seus vizinhos
quebrar o gelo perguntar se a pessoa tem
açúcar para emprestar né e aí o que
acontece
ontem açúcar as pessoas começaram a usar
né e elas uma vez que elas se empolgaram
de emprestar coisa mas para as outras
ela se empolgaram e fazer muitas outras
coisas então as pessoas começaram não só
a compartilhar objetos mas é e de ajudas
e gentilezas e coisas assim então por
exemplo um amigo meu que mora no bairro
que só tem 50 pessoas cadastradas não
tem açúcar
ele pediu para ver se alguém poderia
cuidar do cachorro dele enquanto ele
viajava e molhar hortinha dele e aí no
bairro de 50 pessoas sete pessoas se
ofereceram para fazer isso de graça sem
ganhar nada por isso talvez vão ganhar
uma lambida do cachorro dele um abraço
do cachorro ele é muito fofo mas assim
fora isso essas pessoas fizeram isso por
pura gentileza é então a gente começou a
ver que as pessoas estavam querendo e
além dos empréstimos elas queriam
colaborar entre si é de outras formas
e aí hoje em dia a gente inclusive
fazendo uma campanha de financiamento
coletivo para poder facilitar com que eu
tenha açúcar desse próximo passo que é
de virar uma rede de colaboração local
entre vizinhos
é uma das coisas que eu mais fico
enfim
de está participando da da economia
colaborativa e da economia do
compartilhamento
a idéia de que o seu crédito né
é a sua reputação a sua forma de acesso
ao que você precisa é a sua reputação ou
seja o que você faz pelas outras pessoas
e eu acho lindo o fato de que a
abundância na economia colaborativa ela
não vem da quantidade de dinheiro que
você tem
ela vem das relações que você cria
obrigado